please welcome Ben Stiller
that's me that even new to the big well
I think about God piss-poor a scam that
means this seemed like a better idea in
rehearsal this is between this and the
Nazi uniform but the show seemed a
little Hitler heavy so
I am here to present the award for best
makeup
the ironic thing is avatar hasn't even
nominated should just wore my Spock ears
because Star Trek was actually nominated
and I own two pairs from the original
series both signed by Leonard Nimoy but
that would have been too nerdy this is
much cooler
cut your margins come ranking of the
world
woman Nakia yeah West ICU I want to plug
my tail
my braids into your dragon and my tail
I brought a hairnet it's okay
after I announced the winner I will try
to stand as far away from them as
possible so as not to demean their
moment of triumph
and the winner is okay all right all
right now no no okay
no no sorry sorry dude it's all right
thank you
it's amazing how far technologies come
all right
the winner is Star Trek Barney Berman
Mindy ha Joe Harlow
first Academy Award and nomination for
Barney Herman Mindy Hall and Joel Harlow
I don't want to step on your tail it's
hard to follow that face we thank you
the Khadem II we thank JJ Abrams your
your vision inspired us your energy kept
us going and your insistence on
perfection brought us here
we thank bad robot Paramount Pictures we
felt your support every day we had an
amazing staff artists over 40 we share
this with you and will be given your
names backstage with that backstage
thank you cam thank you very much happy
Anniversary baby